we're about 100 people
and we're really passionate about space
and space adventure games and science
fiction in general and a lot of us grew
up in the
end of the 80s and you know at this time
like you had like star fox i grew up
with with star fox it was my first 3d
game and it was it blew my mind like it
was on super nintendo it was like
polygons it was crazy
and so but a lot of us like you know
movies about space adventures tv shows
that had
toys as well that were connected to the
to the tv show so comic books like so a
lot of us grew up with all those
references and so uh yeah starlink is
really born from our our passion for for
space and
and all those space adventures that we
grew up with being kids
it was a mix you know of
excitement
stress but also excitement
and more stress also
and it's because
you know like you're pitching the game
to nintendo
quarters to
pitch to mr miyamoto and the original
star fox team so it's like your heart is
racing you know
and it's kind of a once-in-a-lifetime
uh
thing
so it was important that uh this game
starting had to be something completely
new that you have not seen before the
challenge was how do you
integrate the building part of the game
into the gameplay basically it was
important for us that um each planet
would be very unique so
what we've done with our
narrative narrative team and also our
art team is that we before even creating
the worlds we started to build the
geological story of those worlds because
each of those worlds have different
creatures have different vegetation and
so you can see the creatures how they
evolve and there's and you can scan
those creatures and if you scan enough
of those creatures you'll uh you'll
discover more you have a database in the
game and you'll learn more about how
they live on those worlds and how
they've evolved so it was a lot it was
very important for us that
when you do the feeling of exploration
that is completely you can explore those
worlds completely seamlessly from one
world to another
is really rewarded but by the uniqueness
of each of those worlds and that was
also a desire from the team from us that
to really have this range of worlds that
you think you've seen it before but it's
different and worlds that you've never
seen it before this idea of
reconfiguring on the fly and create your
own personal story so of course this is
there's a story in the in the game that
and all the characters you have
different personalities so you can play
the whole game with fox if you want but
you can also play the whole game with
judge or with hunter or you can keep
swapping between those pilots and you
will
you will have their own personality
looking at the events that are opening
and starting so i think this is
something really cool and
i think that uh
players have not experienced something
like this where you actually build a
starship you choose your combination in
real life i think this is something
really new that
uh that is really interesting and that
players uh didn't experience before
also i mean we've done we've put a lot
of care and love into those those
starships and i think that if you look
at the quality of those models of the of
the ships but also the pilots and the
weapons they look absolutely gorgeous
and
and and it's really something that we're
very proud and because we wanted
starship that looks more like
collectibles but collectibles that you
can interact with so they're not fragile
you can you can play with them you can
mix and match and just like put it
together like and and this is something
that is challenging to do but i think
we've managed to to reach a balance of
like looking absolutely gorgeous and
being playable with when you play uh
with fox mcleod in the r wing on the
unintended on nintendo switch at 20 of
course uh you're gonna realize that fox
is a bit more than just a guess you're
gonna see uh falco sleepy and pepe that
are gonna be that are gonna be there as
well they're gonna talk to the starting
team and and with fox all together to
try to figure out uh how to adapt to
overcome to what's happening in the in
the story of starling and uh they're in
search of wolf o'donnell the legendary
uh
so there's different types of enemies in
the game with different size and you can
see all the weapons have different um
energy in them
whether it's like a crush energy or
frost energy and when you mix and match
them you're going to discover new combos
so
like for example if you mix and match
your fling tour and your frost barrage
you can chill down the enemies with this
one so it will slow them down and then
you can use flamethrower to create like
thermal shock but what's cool and this
is why we call it crave combat is that
even if you don't combos weapons
together the weapons are fun on their
own then we get some enemies in the game
that are smaller and are running on the
ground when they try to latch on the
ship and so what you can do you can set
the ground on fire and the fire will
stay there so when they walk they'll
pass through it and they'll catch fire
and take damage over time so you get
creative combat is that idea of like mix
and matching all of this to create your
play style i think that's that's that's
a big thing
i like judge ability because judge can
slow down time so if there's a lot of
enemy on the battlefield and a lot of
projectiles coming at you you can use
charge ability and slow time slow down
the time for everybody but judge and and
the ship that you're using at this time
will keep their speed so you can just
like see the bullets going like this and
just up slalom between them and flank
the enemies and and destroy the
legion like this so i like this ability
a lot sometimes also some enemies have a
core weight point that is going to stay
open just for a short amount of time so
you can use this ability to kind of like
slow down time and do a lot of damage to
the core of this enemy
before it closes up we did something
really cool so i told you that i grew up
with star fox and something that i
remember is that that first music that
coronary i'm using when you you remember
that music
and so when you use fox ability fox can
call in another star fox member as
support so wherever you are if you're in
space if you're at the surface on the
planet you can use flexibility and
one of the star fox member will come it
can be slippy it can be peppy it can be
falco it's random and uh they will help
you for a limited amount of time but
during that time this is the music
you're gonna hear we re-orchestrated
this music so it's gonna be a i i hope
it's gonna be a big nostalgia for all
star fox fans in the world i hope
players will enjoy the experience what
with what we've been
building for the past five years it's
really been a passion project for us to
be so toronto and i also hope that
players from all age will play with the
game it's also a great game you know you
can play a co-op split screen locally i
also hope secretly i hope that
players will collect the starship and
some of them
because players are very talented so
some of them will repaint it add more
details at like um
enthusiast players who have good skills
on painting models that they would like
push the paint of the ship even further
and come up with crazy paint jobs for
their ships so i hope to see that also
let's be honest here
you guys need all the help you can get
foreign